oh
nein was für ein schmerz
was ist passiert
ich muss mir einen zahn abgebrochen
haben
übertreibe nicht so
übertreiben nicht so
ausschaut aber wenn es so wehtut
solltest du den zahnarzt anrufen aber
wenn es so wehtut solltest du den
zahnarzt anrufen
ich rufe ihn sofort an
ja ich rufe ihn sofort an
guten tag
zahnarztpraxis steiner hier frau müller
guten tag frau müller
ich brauche dringend einen termin beim
zahnarzt
ja klar ich habe einen freien termin
heute abend um 17 uhr 30 ja klar ich
habe einen freien termin heute abend um
17 uhr 30 oder morgen um 11 uhr und am
nachmittag um 15 uhr oder morgen um 11
uhr und am nachmittag um 15 uhr ich
komme um 17 uhr 30 danke
ich komme um 17 uhr 30 danke ihr name
bitte
ihr name bitte mein name ist luca
fischer
ein name ist luca fischer
gut herr fischer der termin ist gebucht
wir sehen uns heute abend
perfekt vielen dank
willst du in der zwischenzeit etwas
gegen die schmerzen
hallo guten abend hallo guten abend
ich habe einen termin
mein name ist luca fischer mein name ist
luca fischer hallo herr fischer
bitte nehmen sie noch kurz platz
die zahnärztin holt sie gleich
herr fischer kommen sie bitte mit herr
fischer kommen sie bitte mit
bitte setzen sie sich bitte
setzen sie sich sagen sie mir was ist
das problem
sagen sie mir was ist das problem
ich habe einen zahn der weh tut ich habe
einen zahn der weh tut
ich fühle die hitze und die kälte
und mein zahnfleisch ist geschwollen
ok dann war ihr letzter zahnarztbesuch
wann war ihr letzter zahnarztbesuch
leicht vor zwei jahren
vielleicht vor zwei jahren
ok zuerst machen wir ein röntgenbild und
dann schauen wir mal nach
zuerst machen wir ein röntgenbild
schauen wir mal nach
bitte legen sie sich jetzt hin bitte
legen sie sich jetzt hin
öffnen sie den mund weit
es ist dieser backenzahn richtig
ja
es ist nicht sehr ernst
sie haben eine kleine karius die sie
entfernen müssen sie haben eine kleine
karies die sie entfernen müssen
zum glück ist die karies nicht sehr tief
soll ich sie jetzt entfernen oder
möchten sie wiederkommen soll ich sie
jetzt entfernen oder möchten sie
wiederkommen nein wenn es möglich ist
möchte ich sie jetzt entfernen lassen
nein wenn es möglich ist möchte ich sie
jetzt entfernen lassen
natürlich natürlich
ich werde den bohrer verwenden um die
karies zu entfernen und dann werde ich
die füllung machen
ich werde den bohrer verwenden um die
karies zu entfernen und dann werde ich
die füllung machen
ich mache ihnen eine kleine anästhesie
damit sie keine schmerzen führen ich
mache ihnen eine kleine anästhesie damit
sie keine schmerzen fühlen öffnen sie
gut den mund jetzt gebe ich ihnen eine
kleine spritze
so schauen vorbei haben sie schmerzen
gespürt so schon vorbei haben sie
schmerzen gespürt
nein gar nicht
nein gar nicht super jetzt
spülen sie gut mit wasser
super jetzt
spielen sie gut mit wasser gut warten
wir eine minute bis die anästhesie wirkt
gut warten wir eine minute bis die
anästhesie wirkt jetzt benutze ich den
us pirat ohr
jetzt benutze ich den us pirat ohr
wenn sie einen schmerz fühlen heben sie
bitte die hand und ich höre sofort auf
wenn sie einen schmerz führen heben sie
alles klar
los geht's
[Musik]
sie waren gut sehr gut sie waren gut zum
verschließen der kavität verwende ich
die hartz passte zum verschließen der
kavität verwende ich die hartz passte
jetzt hätte ich die paste mit dem blauen
licht aus jetzt hätte ich die paste mit
dem blauen licht aus
spülen sie bitte noch einmal mit wasser
wunderbar herr fischer wir haben es
geschafft
geschafft wie fühlen sie sich
alles gut wie fühlen sie sich
alles gut ja es geht
ja es geht
ok also sie haben eine leichte
zahnfleischentzündung wegen des
zahnstein
ok also sie haben eine leichte
zahnfleischentzündung wegen des
zahnstein
wann haben sie das letzte mal eine
zahnreinigung gemacht
zahnreinigung gemacht vor mindestens
drei oder vier jahren vor mindestens
drei oder vier jahren
das ist nicht gut ich rate ihnen das so
schnell wie möglich zu tun
wenn sie möchten kann ich ihnen einen
termin geben wenn sie möchten kann ich
ihnen einen termin geben wenn sie alle
plaques und den zahnstein entfernt haben
wird das zahnfleisch besser wenn sie
alle plaques und den zahnstein entfernt
haben wird das zahnfleisch besser
gut wir sind fertig für heute
bitte denken sie daran kein essen und
keine warmen getränke bis zum abend
keine warmen getränke bis zum abend wenn
sie keine anderen probleme haben können
wir uns nächstes jahr zur kontrolle
sehen
wenn sie keine anderen probleme haben
können wir uns nächstes jahr zur
kontrolle sehen danke für alles frau
doktor
danke für alles frau doktor
ich danke ihnen
ich danke ihnen und denken sie daran
ihre zähler dreimal täglich zu putzen
und die zahnseide jeden abend zu
benutzen
und denken sie daran ihre zähne dreimal
täglich zu putzen und die zahnseide
jeden abend zu benutzen ja gut auf
wiedersehen ja gut auf wiedersehen
hallo ich möchte ein den neuen termin
ausmachen
hallo ich möchte einen neuen termin
am besten passt mir immer der
donnerstagnachmittag
hätten sie da etwas frei
nächste woche sind wir nicht da wir sind
im urlaub
wir können uns die folgende woche wieder
treffen donnerstag um 16 uhr ok
nächste woche sind wir nicht da wir sind
im urlaub
wir können uns die folgende woche wieder
treffen donnerstag um 16 uhr ok
ja gut ja gut
perfekt herr fischer wir sehen uns in
zwei wochen
schönen abend
perfekt herr fischer wir sehen uns in
zwei wochen
schönen abend
dankte ebenfalls
danke ebenfalls
ich habe zahnschmerzen
beim bauen
beim trinken
ich brauche
einen zahnarzt
eine zahnärzten
beim zahnarzt anrufen
welcher fan tut weh
die zahn extraktion einen zahn ziehen
die zahnspange
der zahnersatz
das zahnfleischbluten
der zahnbelag
der stift zahn
sich einen zahn abbrechen
das loch die karies
der zahnschmelz
die zahnseide
ich hoffe das video war für dich
nützlich und du hast neue wörter gelernt
wenn dir das video gefallen hat
gib uns einen daumen hoch und denkt
daran
der gute mundhygiene sehr wichtig ist
zum nächsten video